ich kann wirklich gar nicht sagen warum
die für mich ausgeliehen schmetterlinge
aber sie sieht halt auf dem
schmetterling
[Musik]
hey leute was die ab jetzt willkommen
bei neuen video ja heute also erstmal so
kennt ihr das zu ihr seid auf instagram
oder sonstwo unterwegs und es gibt ja
immer irgendwelche instagram [ __ ] die
es übertreiben übertreibt es einfach so
da denkst du dir sicher bist du dumm ist
auch eigentlich überhaupt nicht witzig
so ich dachte mir so wieso macht man
dass man das sieht doch jeder vollidiot
dass das bild ein bisschen viel geld und
genau deshalb gibt es heute dieses video
die dümmsten photoshop girls also
wirklich aber er war ich habe euch
einmal auftritt gefragt hier könnt ihr
eure photoshop girls face schicken also
wenn ihr irgendwelche gesehen habt oder
so dann schickt mir das einfach und ich
habe mir natürlich auch selber ein paar
rausgesucht die gucken wir uns jetzt
gleich mal zusammen an und dann wird mal
ein bisschen abgelästert 12 so ich würde
sagen wir fangen mit dem ersten foto und
heute ist es wirklich so da sind die
roten kreis auf dem segway wirklich
berechtigt so ich würde sagen wir fangen
mit diesem bild ja also wenn ich das
erstmal so angucke denken nicht so ist
schon ganz okay aber wenn man genau
hinguckt und du bist jetzt auf die roten
kreise achtet die heute wirklich sinn
ergeben in diesem video sieht man junge
mann das ist dumm einfach stimmt sie hat
erst mal ganz einfach ihre teil hier
oder wie das heißt ein bisschen dünn
gemacht das erkennt man ganz einfach da
an diesem bürger steigt der halt so
eingeknickt ist an diesem fall oder an
diesem roten kreis ganz oben und dann
hat sie einfach auf den arsch bisschen
dicker gemacht das erkennt man auch ganz
einfach an dem teil da unten da ist halt
eigentlich ganz normal immer einen
gerade strich weil da ein pflasterstein
kommt und dann eine rente aber bei ihr
seid so dann ist plötzlich dieser
pflasterstein da unten so komisch
gewölbt und dann sieht man das auch noch
mal da ist total um so ein richtig
komischer weicher übergang zwischen ihr
und dem bodensee tier das sogar unten
rechts an immer schon das gleiche ist
auf der linken seite mädchen wie blöd
ich verstehe nicht wie man so dumm sein
kann das sieht doch jeder blinder mit
krückstock egal ich würde mich gar nicht
weiter drüber aufregen wir machen weiter
mit diesem bild ja das hat mir jemand
geschickt und kann jetzt ein film
erwarten
die hat einfach ihre schuhe noch mal
übermalt oder locker alter
überhaupt nicht auch so aber das hast du
wirklich gut gemacht mädchen das hast du
gut gemacht so ich habe es gerade erst
nicht gecheckt deswegen wenn ich jetzt
bei instagram so durchscrollen würde ich
würde denken so die rechten schuhe sind
schon ganz cool
die linken die schwarze schuhe sind auch
cool ich finde das ist jetzt gar nicht
so schlimm so legen wie es ja auch voll
witzig das ist zwar ein feld aber der
ist wahrscheinlich extra wenn nicht dann
tut mir auch leid aber man sieht dein
gesicht ja ähnlich so leute kommen wir
zum nächsten bild das ist dieses hier
jeder gleiches prinzip wie eben
sie macht aber dieses doch einfach erst
mal auf der einen seite die tür der
türrahmen geht natürlich so und auf der
anderen seite hat sich einfach was hast
du mit deinem arm gemacht erst mal ist
natürlich das kabel der kamera hier
irgendwo total schief und die arme ist
einfach so dünn warum macht man das ganz
einfach damit ihre titten größer sind ja
fällt natürlich null auf was will man
dazu noch sagen die frisur ist auch
heftig die augen sind auch passend
geschminkt zur frisur farbe so läuft das
und wir können wir schon zum nächsten
will das ist dieses wunderschöne bild
hier
ich finde irgendwie die sieht aus wie
ein schmetterling ich kann wirklich gar
nicht sagen warum die für mich aussieht
wie ein schmetterling aber sie sieht aus
wie ein schmetterling weil du bist jetzt
vielleicht diese augen gesehen auf
schmetterlingsflügeln eltern auf diese
augen braune die hat einfach komplett
ihre augenbrauen abrasiert und so im
strich dahin gemalt oder die hat doch
sogar zwei augenbrauen oder das sind
doch eine augenbraue über der augenbraue
also ich finde sowas überhaupt nicht
mehr attraktiv klar ein bisschen
schminken geht immer aber die sich gar
nicht mehr aus wie ein mensch die sieht
einfach aus wie ein schmetterling okay
allerdings regt sich nicht weiter auf
wir kommen hier schon zum netz mild war
auch wieder sein geld das durch ihre
photoshops gegend wie mit tsunami im
hintergrund ausgelöst hat dass die zu
aus als wärst du halt dünn und im
hintergrund wird ein tsunami auf dich
zukommen und bei diesem foto werden die
roten kreise nicht angebracht gewesen
das hätte ich glaube ich auch so erkannt
sowie in den sand mails von manchen
youtuber aber ich mache es ja mal etwas
selber aber manchmal so bei mir ist es
wirklich angebracht da kann es mal
machen finde ich vielleicht nicht immer
aber manchmal schon heute an sonst würde
ich sagen so viele erstmal zu dem thema
gänzlich gefallen hat und dir wirklich
noch im zweiten teil davon sehen wollt
ihr könnt mir natürlich noch weitere
fotos hopp girls dummen fels weil in
zusammen direkt schicken oder so
instagram ist in der video beschreibung
war eben ein geländer
lassen daumen nach oben da für den
zweiten part würde mich sehr freuen
sagen war bei keine ahnung 10.000
leichtbau ich im zweiten teil rausschaut
war denke ich mal locker ins
leitungsnetz war wie gesagt alles
eingebaut nicht unbedingt weiter mit
meinem letzten check das auf jeden fall
ab dann ging es um was jungs wirklich
vom ersten date massen habe ich so ein
bisschen überlegt so dass und das gleich
ansonsten sehen wir uns dann aber die
kommentare wieder ich bin schon einen
schönen teil
aber wenn du genießt das lange
wochenende ps